voilà une réparation bien délicate
effectué et surtout pas que je me tape
sur les doigts parce que ça les fera
soit bonjour j'ai lu et dont tu n'es pas
très en avance un peu trop forte c'est
julie tu as au point perdu trois clients
aujourd'hui j'étais arrivé à bayonne
je me suis aperçu que j'avais oublié les
clés alors je suis parti à la maison les
chercher et puis voilà ça m'a mis en
retard et je les trouve plus là
maintenant olala ça commence à aller mal
ça va mal tu as entendu à votre tête
hein faut mieux avoir des jambes à
tétouan à julie tient que le facteur a
porté pas pour toi mais tu ne mérites
pas mal oui
que veut-il que j'en fasse ça moi j'en
sais rien je pensais que j'étais au
courant oui je me souviens il voulait
les déposer pour que je les donne
comme c'est épouvantable qui at il
encore là mais je me souviens plus si
c'est à casimir ou à monsieur dix neuf
qu'il faut je les donne c'est pas très
grave et continue à quelle est leur
demander mais tu connais casimir il va
dire que c'est à lui même si ça n'est
pas vrai vous salue tous les deux voilà
qu'elle soit serge quoi faire bonjour
casimir que mon métier ça va je suis en
pleine forme je viens de prendre un bon
bain et ça va très bien mais qu'est ce
que tu as derrière ton jeune il ya
quasiment mon panier ne se sont pas niés
voilà qu'est ce qu'on fait ag je joue
avec les enfants d'accord roger au jeu
je justifie les enfants jade et yverdon
nommé casimiro nous allons faire des
mines avec les enfants écoutent
alors écoute casimir est ce que tu a
commandé quelque chose aux facteurs
enfin non je ne pense pas non
enfin écoute qu'est ce que tu as là bon
puisqu'il insiste tant pis - amy tu
n'aurais pas par hasard commandé une
paire de jumelles aux facteurs des
jumelles louis ou est ce qu'il y à des
jumelles je vois pas de jus mais attends
minutes non vous n'êtes pas jumelles un
nom les coudes françois unia coach du
mali six stations am et casimir des
jumelles s'est pas uniquement de deux
filles qui sont nés en même temps qu'ils
se ressemblent comme deux gouttes de
garde c'est aussi cet instrument qui
lorsqu'on regarde dedans fait paraître
quelque chose qui est très loin comme si
c'était proche à la wii ça alors regarde
regarde - françois qu'est ce que tu fais
là bas mais casimir casimir mais je suis
là tout près de toi mon vieux enfin mais
c'est vrai
[Musique]
c'est de l'autre côté
regardez-moi à nouveau à temps oh là là
ça va oui n'a pas changé une roue alors
oh oh j'aurais jamais cru que le petit
bois ça si près j'aimerais le port à
monsieur du snam solution table sur le
pont et casimir c'est pas la peine de
crier comme ça il est très loin il peut
absolument pas t'entendre tu es sûr
qu'il ne m'entends pas et qu'il ne me
vois pas évidemment je suis certains
écoutent en garde à distance du snap
comment vas tu viennes noir qu'est ce
que tu fais elle est classée me redonne
mois-ci jumelles la fin on joue les
hommes et enfin cassé et s'amuser je te
remercie françois tout à l'air tout à
l'heure mais où va t on mais je vais les
porter à me suis dit tu n'appelles sont
à lui casimir ne peut pas avoir des
jumelles puisqu'il ne sait même pas ce
que c'est mais évidemment tu as raison
donc j'avais bien tout de suite
julie attends une minute s'il te plaît
et que j'en dis j'ai vu monsieur de
snobs sur un port je pourrais peut-être
lui porter ses jumelles écoute quasi
muet tu vois elles sont toutes neuves
elles sont fin juillet alors j'évite
situent les classements julie tu me
connais voyons ben oui justement moi
alors tu sais que tu peux avoir
confiance en moi
écoute kazimiya comment comment tout n'a
pas confiance main facile mais ne te
vexe pas tu sais que je me fais du souci
pour un rien lorsque allés lui porter je
serai plus tranquille
bon bah ça va ça va raser quoi même nom
je garde confiance que pendant ce temps
là avait été très gentil il est fermé
merci ça alors c'est incroyable vous
avez vu il n'a même pas confiance en moi
et ça c'est idiot de monsieur bus noble
qu'est ce qu'il va faire qu'une paire de
jumelles un oh oh mais j'ai une idée